بين نهر النيل والبحر المتوسط تتوسط
محافظه البرزخ دمياط الشاطئين تتميز
المحافظه بمراكب الصيد وصناعه السفن
بانواعها
[موسيقى]
محافظه دمياط والتحديدا مدينه عزبه البرج
موقعها الاستراتيجي على نهر النيل والبحر
الابيض المتوسط
ثقافه كل اهالي المدينه بالبحر وعلاقتهم
بالبحر اللي اتولدوا موجودين فيه البحر
المحيط بالبحاوط البلد يعني تطلع من
الجهاد البحر ومن جهاد البحر فهو اكثر كل
صيادين صناعه الصيد والسفن هي فاميلي
بيزنس عندنا وعند المدينه بالكامل
[موسيقى]
هو في مركب خشب دي خشب خالص بس بخشب من
الخشب خالص في المركب ثاني خشب وفايبر زي
اللي احنا بنعملها ورانا دي دي عمر اطول
والمركب الحديد برضو لها عمر
الخشب حرف هاند ميد يعني كانت بتعتمد على
صنعه وحرفيه قوي من العامل وحاليا المنتج
الجديد محتاج وقت سريع منتج ثابت ويتم فيه
التطوير والله هو حاليا يعني ان ما فيش
شغل موجود زي الاول مش كفايه مش كفايه لكن
الاول كان كفايه ويفيض منه كمان لان كان
الشغل موجود بصفه دايمه على طول لكن حاليا
مش موجود زي الاول
[موسيقى]
اغلاء الاسعار والناس بدات تقل وطبعا شغل
الفايبر يعني بيقل من شغل الخشب لان
الفايبر عمره اطول بيعيش ما بيصينش كل سنه
زي الخشب الخشب مثلا كل ست شهور او كل سنه
بيتصيد لكن الفيبر ما فيش صيانه
[موسيقى]
هي ممكن تختفي ممكن ما تختفيش يعني مثلا
الناس اللي بيحبوها اللي هم متواجدين فيها
حاليا ماشي دولت ممكن يورثهم حبا فيها ومع
التطور اللي فيها لكن الشباب اللي طالع
بيحاول ان هو يبعد عنها لان الشباب عايز
الراحه مش عايز مجهود وعايز تعب شبهنا كده
يعني اكيد في الفتره الحاليه احنا بنواجه
مشاكل في الثروه البشريه اللي موجوده او
اليد العامله المدربه الاول كانت المركب
بتاخد وقت كتير لان كان الشغل كله يدوي ما
كانش فيه تطور ما كانش فيه المعدات اللي
هي الموجوده حاليا وقبل كده ما كانش فيه
الكهرباء موجوده
النهارده في تطور في معدات كفايه
والكهرباء موجوده كفايه يعني زمان ممكن
مثلا تاخد لها اسماء مثلا سنه ونص كان
شغلي يدوي دلوقتي ممكن تاخد لها سنه الاول
كان العماله كانت كتير لان في اللي بيشيل
واللي بيشتغل واللي مساعد واللي مش مساعد
اما النهارده طبعا مع الكمبيوتر
وتكنولوجيا ديت كله بقى بينزل رسومات تمام
ومقاسات يعني بتنفذ على طول
[موسيقى]